yesterday I told you that Donald Trump
pulled former CIA director John
Brennan's security clearance and of
course it was a completely political
move noting Brennan did really indicates
that he is erratic or untrustworthy with
whatever information he could have
access to and of course is someone who's
not actually consulting for the
president as many former intelligence
officials do it's not even really clear
that he regularly was accessing or
receiving classified information but
that was yesterday the more interesting
new angle on this and this is something
I didn't think about yesterday was the
removal of the security clearance
not only from John Brennan but the
threat of removals from other people
whether it's DNI clapper former DNI
clapper or other individuals James Comey
could it be a pretext or a precursor to
removing special prosecutor Robert
Muller's security clearance which by the
way would make it very difficult for him
to carry out the Trump Russia
investigation now but before we get into
the details and what Senator Mark Warner
believes about this remember that the
reality is that it's Trump who's the
existential risk when it comes to
security clearances and classified
information while taking away other
people's security clearances Trump
welcomed a Russian spy recruiter to the
Oval Office and spilled classified
information and secrets to him that came
to us from an ally Israel at the real
risk of ruining that relationship with
an ally so the real risk with soap with
security clearances and classified info
is Trump okay not John Brennan Senator
Mark Warner who's the top Democrat on
the Senate Intelligence Committee he put
out the idea earlier this week that
President Trump revoking John Brennan's
security clearance maybe setting up a
pretext or precedent for doing the exact
same thing to special prosecutor Robert
Muller there's a certain evil genius to
this he is a former intelligence
official his role now is special
prosecutor it would be pretty tough for
him to run the Trump Russia
investigation without a security
clearance
and Warner said in a statement of excuse
me about this quote I worry whether this
precedence will lead to the president
trying to take away molar and his whole
team's security clearance this is
clearly another effort to silence
critics and not allow the molar
investigation and for that matter our
Senate intelligence community
investigation to get to the bottom of
this I think that this is a very
interesting angle because Trump has a
long history of using varied methods to
try to prevent that investigation from
actually happening
he fired James Comey at least in part to
interrupt and interfere with that
investigation he's angry that Jeff
Sessions recused himself on everything
related to Trump Russia because had he
not sessions could be running
interference and trying to get that
investigation to stop he has been
talking to Republicans in the House and
Senate about can't we get this thing
wrapped up his lawyers in their
negotiations with Muller about the we
still don't know if it'll happen
possible interview with President Trump
we know that the idea of he'd consider
talking to Muller
if Moeller commits to ending the
investigation at a particular time
something I hope Robert Muller would
never actually consider doing but
certainly something that Donald Trump's
lawyers might want him to do look at how
far we've come there was a time when
President Obama killed a fly during an
interview and it was major news there
was a time when President Obama wore a
tan suit on a day where he was
discussing something serious and he was
attacked for days by right-wing media
we've got a president now playing
politics with security clearances the
security clearance of top intelligence
officials like former CIA director John
Brennan and his supporters like it they
see this as Trump fighting fighting to
defend himself and of course the best
way to defend yourself the best way to
clear your name if you are indeed
innocent is let the investigation finish
and clear you if that's what it's
actually going to to to do now I do have
one hope
pulling the security clearance for a
special prosecutor
if Trump did it that would be very clear
of justice wouldn't it and I would
imagine I would hope that whoever
replaces Robert Muller because the
investigation doesn't just end if you
pull the security clearance from Robert
Muller I hope that in that case molars
replacement would realize that the act
of pulling the security clearance from
Muller is an act of obstruction of
justice and maybe act on it I don't know
I want to talk to the Republicans though
where are you on this if the Republicans
are the strongest supporters of not only
the military as they claim to be but
also the hard-working men and women of
our intelligence community why are they
silent why are they allowing people like
John Brennan and everybody else who
clearly is at risk of having their
security clearance pulled
why aren't they rioting hypothetically
or at least writing letters or showing
up on media and saying we can't allow
this to happen we can't allow them to be
treated in this way and the answer is
they're complicit in all of it and
they're not going to do a damn thing the
people that right now are running the
House and Senate Republicans in the
House and Republicans in the Senate they
are not going to hold anyone accountable
when it comes to trump Russia or Trump's
inner circle the only path forward is to
win in November and to win to november's
from that in 2020 because this stuff you
and I might see it and say wait if you
there's someone doing an investigation
and it's in to the president and then
the president pulls their security
clearance and now they can't do that
investigation anymore that seems like a
problem that seems like it should be a
crime that seems like there should be
repercussions we get it the Republicans
who are in charge have made it
abundantly clear that they won't do
anything about it and they've even gone
further and made it very clear that even
if Robert Moeller were to come back in
three months or in six months or nine
months and say here's the list of stuff
these are criminal actions by the
president you can't indict a sitting
president so you Republicans in the
House and Senate need to move to impeach
they're not going to do it they are not
going to do it there is no indication
that that's something they're going to
do and thus we've got a vote in November
and we've got a vote in the following
November as well we have a fantastic
bonus show for
you today on the bonus show today we are
going to go into identity politics is
that true well not really we are going
to talk about an issue of identity and
that is the issue of Donald Trump having
no african-american senior White House
staff now some people in the audience
will say David who cares why are you
categorizing people on the basis of
their race that's racist
you are the racist for even noticing it
I don't think that's going to be too
many people in the bonus show audience
but maybe people listening to this
preview we are also going to talk on the
bonus show about back pain which is
something we've talked about on the show
quite a bit in terms of its connection
to sort of Western work culture as well
as psychosomatic pain and there are some
interesting new data points about back
pain and sitting and people working in
offices and then we also have some very
interesting announcements to make about
the next few weeks for the David Pakman
show and if you are curious about what
those announcements are these are I
would call these pretty major
announcements about the David Pakman
show earlier in the week we announce
that we hit 500,000 YouTube subscribers
this is a different type of announcement
so if any of that sounds interesting or
if it doesn't then you just want to
support the show please consider signing
up for membership at WWJ pakman.com you
can save 40% using the coupon code vote
soon 18 and of course patreon is always
available you can also access the bonus
show when you make a pledge of at least
5 bucks a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show
it is Friday we will be taking your
calls answering your questions and much
much more upcoming today's show is made
possible in part by news voice comm /
hackman we have talked on this program
for a year after year after year how
American media is controlled by just a
small handful really of huge
corporations and the problem with having
media conglomerates among others is that
you get filter bubbles you get echo
chambers and this is something I talked
about on the program a lot there's a new
media company that's come up with an
interesting response to this problem
it's called
newse voice and what it is is a website
and app for both iOS and Android which
gives you a personalized newsfeed by
aggregating a mix of mainstream media
sources along with international sources
and independent media sources
importantly so any story you look at you
will get multiple sources you can upvote
stories you think are important so that
more people will see them you can add a
story to the site you can add a source
that's missing for a particular story
and the idea is for it to be completely
open and democratized as a source of
news and you can get every side of every
story check out the app which you can
download for free if you go to news
voice calm slash Pakman if you're
watching this on youtube simply click
the link below the video